قال الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن
نصر الله ان اغتيال القيادي في حركه حماس
صالح العاروري في الضاحيه الجنوبيه امر
خطير جدا وانه يحصل للمره الاولى منذ عام
2006 واضاف نصر الله في خطاب له في الذكرى
الرابعه لاغتيال رئيس فيلق القدس في الحرس
الثوري الايراني قاسم سليماني ان جريمه
اغتيال العاروري لن تبقى دون رد
وعقاب بالحادثه
امس المقاومه
وعدت وان كانت في ظروف مختلفه لم تكن هناك
حرب وتغيير في كثير من معادلات الصراع
ولكن هذا لن يغير من الوعد شيئا الجريمه
امس هي جريمه كبيره وخطيره ولا يمكن
السكوت عليها والامر لا يحتاج الى الكثير
من الكلام وكما قلنا في بيان حزب الله امس
هذه الجريمه الخطيره لن تبقى دون رد
وعقاب لن تبقى دون رد وعقاب وبيننا
وبينكم الميدان والايام
والليالي